Donald Trump is set for a long time
China's bad China's eating our lunch
economically they're laughing at us we
have to start buying American we have to
bring back American manufacturing jobs
we have to beat China again because we
don't win anymore and you might remember
he talked about this during his
inauguration speech but we have now
found out sit down while Trump was
giving that speech we've now learned
that a53 tongue shipment of clothing was
being imported from China by Ivanka
Trump for her clothing line at least 82
shipments of Ivanka Trump's clothing
were shipped in from China between
Election Day and February 26th these
shipments included blouses leather
wallets and shoes all from China this
isn't new I've told you before that over
a thousand shipments of Trump branded
products have come to the United States
from China and Hong Kong an
investigation last July found that not
one single item in Trump's clothing line
sold at the main Macy's store in New
York City was made in the United States
most made in China and Vietnam during
his inauguration speech Trump railed
against American companies for using
overseas labor one of his actual lines
on Inauguration Day was quote we will
follow two simple rules by American and
hire American but remember this
cringe-worthy awkward moment on the Dave
Letterman Show I have nothing against
China I just hate that their leaders are
so much smarter than our leaders 2016 we
will not be the world leader anywhere we
have been always what one is to be
willing gentlemen I marked a great
economic leader even as a line of
clothing no where were these made these
were made I don't know where they were
made but they were made someplace but
they're great its ties shirts cufflinks
everything sold at Macy's and they're
doing great number one selling tie
anywhere in the world number one a
letter I anywhere in the world oh that's
right you wouldn't wear that you also
haven't been white and beautiful why are
the shirts made Bangladesh what is good
we employ people in Bangladesh and highs
wear the tie they awarded a beautiful
ties
they are great tie the ties are made in
where China
chyna right right we talked about the
other day how Kelly and Conway was
probably breaking federal law when she
used her White House position to promote
promote Ivanka Trump's clothing line
it's particularly perverse when you
consider that Kellyanne Conway was
promoting Chinese made clothes in
violations of ethics laws and it worked
because sales of Ivanka's products have
been seeing a huge spike even though
Nordstrom dropped the line for clothes
overall I have been seeing a huge spike
in sales so China's behind the climate
change hoax and they're also at fault
for stealing American jobs by letting
American companies have their goods
manufactured in China and companies like
the Trump Organization and Ivanka Trump
are buying from China but I guess Pat if
you ask right-wingers and Trumpets the
real bad guy here it's Nordstrom who
treated Ivanka unfairly by dropping her
clothing line due to lack of demand I
mean I don't think it's necessarily
hypocritical that she's importing
Chinese goods based on the quotes that
her father's may know Asian Trump who's
the hypocrite
well that and Ivanka has taken a role in
the White House even though she doesn't
have an official title because of
anti-nepotism laws yeah but she's taken
part in policy meetings her own husband
is involved in the administration except
I think that's where the hypocrisy comes
in now some trumpets are defending this
and saying no it's not hypocrisy
Patrick Ford is wrong it is not
hypocrisy because a lot of companies do
this and to compete Donald has to do it
and Ivanka has to do it Trump doing this
doesn't mean he can't criticize the
system blame the game not the player
blah blah blah but manufacturing your
own goods in China is not a rule of the
game and you don't have to do it
especially if you're a loud outspoken
critic of outsourcing manufacturing
which Trump has been for a long time
this is the definition of hypocrisy and
if there's anyone who should lead by
example it's someone who is the
president of the US and their family and
someone who has the deep enough pockets
to do it like as a billionaire who can
afford to manufacture the products
wherever it is that he wants you can
advocate changing the system without
explore
leading the status quo and actually
being an acute part of the problem
Ivanka is a part of the problem and so
is Donnie I mean this is nothing new
Trump supporters elected a billionaire
who's contributed millions of dollars to
complete achill campaigns over the years
to break up the system and drain the
swamp and they elected someone who is
hired Polish immigrants who worked here
illegally and now is the person that is
going to be a champion for building a
wall and against illegal immigration yes
and unsurprisingly Donald Trump doing
many of the things that he claimed to be
against during the campaign and not
doing many of the things that he said he
would before during the campaign at this
point it's more sad than funny